(Viserys): The Targaryens, blood of the
dragon, and the last of old Valyria,
were loved by their subjects
and admired far and wide
as the greatest dynasty
in the history of the western world.
But the peace and prosperity
of nearly three centuries of Targaryen rule
were shattered by the Usurper,
Robert Baratheon,
and his band of traitors.
House Baratheon owed
its very existence to the Targaryens.
Was it not Aegon the Dragon himself
who elevated the bastard Orys Baratheon
in the War of Conquest?
And what of the Starks?
The Lannisters?
The Arryns of the Vale?
All had been spared
and allowed to keep their lands
when Aegon could
easily have wiped them out.
Centuries later,
the Usurper and his lackeys
repaid Aegon's benevolence
with treachery.
There are some who dare to claim
Robert and his allies had reason to rebel.
They say the crown prince
stole the Usurper's lady love.
They say my father, King Aerys,
murdered Rickard Stark and his son
without just cause.
Whether these charges are true or not,
it doesn't matter.
The dragon answers to no one.
Aerys' good name has been besmirched
in the years since the rebellion.
He has been called
a dangerous madman, a monster,
a tyrant that brought
his tragic end upon himself.
Lies!
My father was a victim
of weaklings in his council,
lack-wits who failed him
in his hour of need
and let the rebellion spin out of control.
But it was not enough.
The royal army was crushed
at the Battle of the Trident.
It was there the valiant Rhaegar
met Robert in single combat,
but the gods betrayed him...
and he perished by the Usurper's hand.
As the Field of Fire had marked
the end of the Andals centuries before...
the Battle of the Trident seemed
to herald the end of the dragon kings.
When word reached the capital
of my brother Rhaegar's death,
my father Aerys moved to protect me,
as I was the surviving heir to the throne.
He sent me to the
island fortress of Dragonstone,
along with my mother, Queen Rhaella,
who was great with child.
But as my father, my king...
Aerys Targaryen...
prepared to defend his throne
to the bitter end...
little did he know
of the horrors and betrayals
that awaited him and our family.